Gender and sexuality are two concepts that are incredibly individualized and so it shouldn't be surprising
That they are so complex
It can be hard to navigate the world of sexuality due to the different terms and labels, this video
Aims to help you navigate this world by arming you with some definitions and examples of 10 different sexualities
Some of which you might not even know about
1.
Bisexuality: the definition for bisexuality is actually something that's debated
Originally, the standard definition was attraction to both genders
However, as understanding of gender has evolved people have argued for an evolved definition of bisexuality
Some use the definition of attraction to your own and other genders to incorporate non-binary genders within its definition
Some famous examples of people who are bisexual are Brandon Urie (he is actually Pansexual witch is discussed later in the video)  from the band Panic at the Disco and actress Angelina Jolie
2.
Homosexuality: this is one of the terms that most people tend to be familiar with, it means attraction to one's own gender and is sometimes
referred as gay (Male or female) or lesbian (Female only)
Famous examples include comedian Alan Carr and presenter Sue Peterson
3. Heterosexuality:
Heterosexuality is probably the most well known sexuality and whether right or wrong it is often thought of as the default
This is known as heteronormativity. It means attraction to genders other than your own
It's most commonly used to refer to binary genders
4.
Pansexuality:
Pansexuality is defined as an attraction to all genders
Some say those who are pansexual don't care about gender when it comes to their attraction though, Not all agree with this assessment
Some people also use the sexuality and bisexuality
Interchangeably Miley Cyrus is a notable person who is pansexual
5.
Polysexuality:
Polysexuality refers to people who are attracted to two or more genders
typically bisexuality and pansexuality
are types of polysexuality, though not all people who are polysexual use these terms
6.
Asexuality:
Asexuality is one of the lesser known sexualities. It refers to someone who doesn't experience sexual attraction to any gender
This doesn't mean however, that they never have relationships or sex which are common myths about asexuality
Bojack horseman the TV show explores asexuality through one of the major characters Todd Chavez
7. Grey-asexuality: This is similar to the previous sexuality
However, instead of never experiencing sexual attraction someone who is grey-sexual may very rarely experience sexual attraction
They are still valid under the asexuality umbrella despite occasionally experiencing sexual attraction
8.
Demisexuality:
Demisexuality again can technically fall under the asexual umbrella, people who are demisexual do experience sexual attraction
But only after an emotional connection is created
they wouldn't find a stranger on the street sexually appealing but after they get to know someone well, the possibility of sexual attraction is there
Demisexuality is considered the halfway point between asexuality and allo-sexuality those who experience sexual attraction
9. Androsexuality: androsexuality is a sexuality that outside of
LGBTQ circles is not well known at all. It refers to someone who is attracted to a masculine gender presentation
This can refer to anyone of any gender man,woman or non-binary
10. Gynosexuality:  gynosexuality like androsexuality is not well known
It refers to someone who was attracted to a feminine gender presentation
This could again refer to any individual of any gender
We hope you feel more informed about sexuality after watching this video
Which sexuality do you most identify with? Which sexualities were new to you?
Be sure to LIKE this video and SUBSCRIBE to our channel if you'd like more great content.
Check out other Psych2Go videos to learn more about sexualities among other interesting topics this channel covers!!